así es muy buenas tardes pues es la
segunda victoria de la prensa francesa
ante uno de los gigantes de internet
esta vez es facebook facebook que de
hecho pues hizo el anuncio que había
llegado a este acuerdo ante la app y que
la api que que es la alianza de prensa
de información general aquí en el país y
bueno pues el presidente de esta piques
se mostró bastante contento por este
logro lo que hace este acuerdo es
simplemente mostrar cómo va a regir y
bajo qué principios va a regir esa
remuneración por publicar o compartir
contenidos de estos diarios franceses en
facebook como les decía pues a pic de
sede se mostró bastante contenta de
haber llegado a este acuerdo con
facebook sobre todo porque las
remuneraciones van a ser una
financiación muy importante para medios
pequeños a pique pues dentro de esta
alianza están medios grandes como los
mondo luz y gago pero también hay otros
medios más pequeños y lo otro que
resaltaba el presidente de esta alianza
es que todo esto se ha logrado gracias a
la solidaridad es decir que los editores
de prensa han trabajado juntos para
lograr esto dentro de este acuerdo
también se prevé que los medios que
quieran podrán participar en facebook
news este es un espacio que facebook va
a abrir a la actualidad este va a
lanzarse aquí en francia en enero de
2022 pero ya de hecho pues hay un
formato así que está en estudio que ya
están pues ensayándolo en el reino unido